i am uh from the global broadcasts of  chess24 the question is primarily for  magnus and would also love to hear if  ian had a reaction  it appears that today's game was  analyzed in an online database  all the way up until move 20  two days ago  if this was somebody from your team who  forgot to make it private  how would you react  uh  i i don't think um  yeah i don't think anyone any of us can  reasonably uh comment on that  well i i i can only say that normally  you try to switch up this uh online  cloud uh  option in your css base when you analyze  you have to make sure  no one uses  and no one uses let's say uh your  fruitful analysis  but i mean it  could probably be a coincidence as well  okay thank you